use yourself there bro it says
three-time champion
it's like three times oh snap
yeah Clay just Googled itself it's a
three-time champion already that's dope
he's naked you look so happy clay I'm
happy I scored 43 points man would you
be happy Karen of course
Klay Thompson honored the Flint tropics
and so when you're scuffling you need a
little change of Mojo there he is Bob
Myers looking for possible
reinforcements brings out Will Ferrell
tonight they could use it too his energy
is unmatched look at the defensive
stance
working with Clay uh text but close out
that's what we've been talking about
right obviously
[Music]
[Applause]
nah I'm still hot
[Music]
anymore
I'll probably carry that with me
forever
[Music]
oh sorry oh my gosh
I'm sorry I'm sorry uh the man they call
the captain around here
Klay Thompson Embrace Again Play it
certainly feels as if this was one of
the more complete victories you guys
have had in a long time and to do it
against the team that was playing so
well coming into tonight what does this
do for you guys sea captain
yes sir
[Applause]
oh
wow
what happened to the Hat
underestimate the wind gusts man took
her right off my head
oh no
I lost my hat all right question number
two
how much longer until you break Real's
three-point record
I mean you're you're in the in the booth
right now so it's your job to know these
stats to be able to do the quick math
and uh yeah you're supposed to be able
to tell me I don't know where Sammy's at
he's supposed to punch the numbers come
on man oh man how many Bob I don't know
what do you think 40 games it's he's 400
behind Clips oh shoot two seasons
and a half
all right last question of the night
who is a better color commentator Dell
Curry or Michael Thompson and what is
one guy's birthday today so it's your
pop's birthday I'm not saying names
respect happy birthday to to pop pop of
Thompson uh I gotta go Dale Curry though
oh my god oh man what's wrong with
it there and join him nobody enjoys life
the way that Klay Thompson does
sitting right behind the dugout
foreign
oh yeah
these ones which ones do you like and
which one missed the March most
importantly congratulations Mrs Prince
of PESA I love seeing those engagements
here it's always special slow down I
might have butchered your name I'm sorry
but that's right how do you decide who
has to honor a former teammate Steph
Stephen Clay went rock paper scissors
here we go
emotional has ever seen you cried on the
court it obviously was the end of who
cries on the basketball court I mean
stop crying in basketball
[Laughter]
tell us about being over
people were looking for
the worst babysitter on the team would
probably Klay Thompson
um it's about halfway through he might
forget that there's a baby he's
responsible for I would probably say uh
gosh gosh gosh that is a great question
the worst babysitter he would forget
that he was actually babysitting oh man
that's funny
I don't offend anybody no question at
Klay Thompson um
[Music]
I'll probably say uh
fairly worse gosh that's a great
question
can't be one of the older guys because
they'll have children and they're very
good Fathers so I would assume it would
be Jonathan kaminga tends to be
forgetful sometimes and you know you
can't be forgetting somebody's lunch or
nap time and I say JK I don't sorry JK
[Music]
[Applause]
boy what are you noticing about the
energy and the ball movement tonight
that's helping you guys unlock the three
ball
that's great on both both uh
it's great both both of them are great
and um again now pushing the pace that's
what our best
thank you
I think clay clay just he wanted to get
in the locker room he's breathing hard